guys before the video starts off come
together with a brother to raise some
funds for a masjid kalam masjid
in kilburn please help me race for that
the link is in the description box below
enjoy the video in round
out and off and now my kids are learning
in and out and this and that the woman
don't do this man
i'm using a little knitting thing
oh my god mufti men some things i know
that i can't tell you one lie if you
knew you would say
this is not a man i don't know there's
not many you talked about throwing
arrows
let's take it another level what about
shooting yeah shooting
like hunting or target shooting yeah let
me say okay women
is this sexy for you and the women are
saying
my husband doesn't have the libido
the strength why because he's knitting
man you're literally
insulting his integrity
check out our sponsors nature's blends
they specialize in premium ethiopian
black seed products
the website is in the description link
below you can also use the discount code
salaam 10 for 10 of their products
assalamu alaikum brothers and sisters
and dear friends before i start one
praise allah the most merciful the most
trust or praise is glory and gratitude
belong to him
now i came across this video in this
video brother muftimenk
is knitting and there's another brother
who's reacting to him knitting
and he seems a little bit agitated i
know we're going to be discussing this
but
um it's to talk about a bigger problem
as men
how we should conduct ourselves and how
should we act in society as a whole
let's get straight into this video
inshallah and we're going to be going to
uh czechs inshallah oh hi there hijab is
that something you would like to say all
to the audience don't forget to like
share and subscribe otherwise you're
gonna be finished that's correct
so i'm just teaching my children how to
knit i learned to knit when i was six
years old and i remember
the moves in round out and off
in round out and off and now my kids are
learning
i just got them a set of knitting
needles and some huge wool
and we said let's go for it mashallah
you know minky and zinji can have a
little blanket or two
and inshallah we can also spend our time
a little bit constructively so that's
that's round
uh what can i say
if he would have said shoes or his
knitting is
he's fixing his clothes like the hadith
of the prophet saw sallam
and he's teaching his kids like that to
follow that so now
yes he would fix his shoes or but
knitting
oh my god now the brother looks really
really frustrated
and i genuinely believe he is really
frustrated nothing i don't believe he's
putting an act on
and i don't want this video to be an
attack towards him so guys we're not
here yeah he's our brother in islam
we want to understand them yeah now the
thing is he seems very frustrated now
knitting the clothes i mean or your um
shoes or whatever maybe that the
processor sent them done i don't see how
that is far off by knitting
i genuinely do not see it it's it's very
they like come from the same family yeah
so i think that's really neat need to
understand because it's not a big
difference
now yes he can come and say the knitting
is something that women do
uh which we're going to come to later
but let's carry on because i'm just
trying to really understand him here
i'm trying to teach people how to box
how to run
how to take care of them let me have it
this is masculinity
this is sunnah to knit okay guys go
ahead and knit
go ahead and knit if you would have done
the shoes or your clothes as
per the hadith also superman all right
why why do we not ride the horse or
shoot the
arrow or go for swimming or go for a run
or some of the things that are in the
sun of manhood
the process seems described as coming on
a horse with no saddle with a sword
around his neck i'm using a little
knitting thing is that is that the
now i want to touch upon some things
yeah i know mufti man
i know him kind of personally to a level
i know his son
i speak to his son regularly i'm not
doing this video i'm not surprised my
witness before somebody's watching be
like yeah you know you're a
mufti men's fan loyalty with allah and
his messenger
yeah and the muslim mean of course but
i'm not doing this video to suck up the
mufti meng or anything one life if
motivate oppressed somebody
i would try to advise him in private and
if he carries on i will advise him in
public i've got no loyalty to anybody i
don't care how famous he is how many
likes he has well i don't care
ok somebody i do not care but we have to
be just
i understand the brothers frustration
men are not men today they're boys
lucky job says boy boy boy you guys are
boys
this goes with all of us men have lost
their manhood
that's a reality feminist have uh
added to that they've been doing the
reasons etc women are not women today
men are not mentally i understand that
however to pick on somebody because
you see the action of knitting and you
make a connection with that of an
elderly woman
who might be knitting you know a little
woman netting with a few cats etc
is wrong man when you're talking about
brother that boxing etc
look we cannot the process said strong
is not the man who can wrestle somebody
else
but is the one who can control his anger
yeah so if you go to somebody and you're
trying to you know start a fight etc we
cannot
judge based on just what am i seeing you
know what you see that guy who was keep
pushing that guy around or wherever it
may be and that brother you can't say
that guy's a wimp we can't say that
guy's a coward yeah unless he's been
physically attacked
or somebody imagine insulting him and
he's just like laughing yeah
it doesn't mean he's weak at all because
he might have the power to knock that
guy spark out
so just the way we can not just someone
based on that we cannot judge someone
like imagine seeing like a big guy mike
tyson doing knitting
yeah we're not going to say he's not a
man or he's no no we cannot judge
manhood by how harsh you are towards
your wife shut up
yeah i'm gonna put this is toxic
masculinity yeah
to make it seem as if you need to have
this
this persona this the way you have to
behave while light is not manly
there's even times where they say um a
man came to complain about his wife
and he heard um being pulled by the
beard the beard something by the beard
pulled by his wife yeah what we're going
to say
this is your
we cannot judge things by apparent yeah
we can't just be like
yes there is sometimes we can but we
can't judge someone and let me tell you
something
i know muffy mentioned his son you're
talking about horse riding
here's a picture here's a video you can
see on my left on my right
multiman horse riding this is his son
his son is horse riding yeah not only
that you talked about throwing arrows
let's take it another level what about
shooting yeah shooting
like hunting or target shooting yeah
which is nothing wrong
however you need to understand brother
that when these things them
mufti meng as a muslim doing this he
might get in trouble some things i know
that i can't tell you what life if you
knew you would see if this is not a man
i don't know that there's no men he
in one instant he he even fulfilled the
sunnah of slaughter in 63 uh bulls mufti
men
63 bulls that was the son of the prophet
sent them yeah obviously he's not going
to come and share that it's graphic
it's graphics hey guys look and
obviously it was done in the islamic way
yeah
so the thing is this we need to
understand and put things into
perspective
yeah so the things that you talk about
horse riding he does he even trains his
own sons to do it
yeah and i'm going to tell you why he
was doing the knitting we're going to
come to that very soon yeah
and not only that he teaches his sons to
do a lot of things that
men men do yeah for example even when we
can do as well yeah
shooting we are talking shooting hunting
hunting yeah there are some pictures
under the brothers go hunting i'm not
going to share it here but anyways let's
carry on
because i believe that's a misjudgment
and that is not fair but let's carry on
i want to ask the women do you want your
husband to do that i want to ask the man
do you want you and your boys to do that
our sheikhs are teaching us to knit okay
what's the objective of this video
i'll tell you what my objective okay
okay now if i said
mohammed hijab zeeshan musa ustad
now we came together and said let's have
a knitting thing no i would say it's not
something that
we would do yeah it's not something we
would do so that's why we need to put
things into context yeah
he was saying what was the purpose of
this video now this is where
you need to ask this question you could
have got in contact with him private and
say
mufti you know there's this whole
feminine thing you know this super
radical feminist
and you know men are not like men today
some men sadly yeah they are under the
form of their wife
yeah and allah told us that men are the
protectors and maintain this
okay this doesn't mean you become like a
rubber to your wife exception no
me doing certain things in the house
does not make me a woman yeah
so however you're asking why mufti ming
has eight daughters
eight eight eight yeah he said that he's
been knitting since
age of six if we look at the history
there's two links i'm gonna put the
description box here
the history knitting was actually a
man's thing
yeah in the couple of hundred years ago
like in history yeah
if you can read those two links and you
know okay this is
this one of the links here it says when
you purchase when you picture someone
knitting i'll bet that your first
thought is an old lady
sat absent mindedly in her armchair with
a cup of tea maybe
a cat or two terrible cliche i know but
i'll bet for a bunch of you reading this
that's
that's that's what you pictured am i
right is he wrong
well what if i to tell you that the
history of knitting is pretty much the
complete opposite
the current the idea of knitting being a
female focus craft are actually a pretty
modern development
mostly thanks to the changing roles of
women throughout the two world wars
in fact knitting was once thought of an
exclusive gentleman's occupation
involving rigorous testing and
scrutinization with cut fault
competition and code business running
through its core
pretty different that old lady pictured
hey so
these are social constructs okay so we
need to understand that
that is the reason why he's teaching
this to us it's a movie setting we went
out with his losers etc
to teach them that is the content movie
didn't come and say hey guys brothers
leave with what you're doing forget
everything let's knit together
and let's just do this all the time
that's wrong that is
wrong we cannot and let me tell you
something there the hadith of the
prophet
that supports this the person who sallam
said that it is
allah curses the person who dresses up
like a woman and a woman that dressed up
like a man
if muffy men were standing there and put
hijab on himself or makeup
and he was moving like a woman etc i
will understand your frustration full
and i am against this there's some
brothers who do it you know i'm not
gonna give names etc wearing their wives
to drive and put makeup i'm totally
against it i'm so sorry i don't i don't
think there's any reason
to do that it is really wrong and this
says that allah curses that person yeah
okay so the thing is now
the process of sallam said about the
clothing if you dress up like a woman
yeah but he never said or someone that
acts like a woman lose like a woman yeah
however or vice versa however he did not
say
the one who does the drop of a woman
there is no hadith in the quran or the
sunnah that says
the one as far as i know please educate
me as far as i know
there is nothing that says for the man
who does the job of a woman is cursed
or for the woman who does the job of a
man is cursed there's no such thing
because there was
uh um uh female companions who went to
war what we're gonna say that's a man
saying what's she doing there are you
imitating the man
no so when it comes to issue of i can
say for example ironing
uh washing the dishes changing the
baby's nappies and all this kind of
stuff
i'm not going to say now that's a female
thing to do there's not evidence from
quran
yeah there is not to say that if a man
does that he becomes
a woman or he's weak i don't agree with
that you came trying to see with this
social construct to come and say you do
this this is actually
no there is nothing in the prophetic
tradition that says to you
that doing something this specific
action belongs to the woman only one can
do all this
that is not the case i'm so sorry we
have to bring evidence to that
so somebody knitting or doing whatever
it may be
you're washing ironing changing the
baby's nappy or
whatever you can't come and say that is
a female action
you can't say that let's carry it for my
video
is to refute this kind of this kind of
thing because this is just not manly
orange string to knit
in and out and this and that
the woman don't do this man don't you
don't see the sisters doing this
where are the sheikhas the sister
speakers
well hold on a second again you
mentioned an orange color it goes back
to a social construct
it's like saying pink pink is feminine
you can't say but i believe it's a
social construct orange so if it's
orange okay would you look more man if
it was a black one
dark one really black color
come on brother let's be fair here let's
be fair well last time you've done some
horse riding we're wondering why we're
having low testosterone
my clients are coming to me talking
about my husband doesn't want to sleep
with me
women are complaining my husband doesn't
have enough strength as a man
some people
islam started something strange and
returned as something strange
so give glad tidings to the strangers
okay this this statement thinking about
me
i genuinely i know i understand your
frustration i'm with you
but but you you're genuinely what you've
done is you've took a problem
that we have in the ummah we need to fix
and you've picked on somebody
innocent someone innocent and you're
taking it all out on it that's not fair
and now you're quoting about the process
and said that islam came as something
strange and it will remain something
strange so
glad tidings to the strangers well like
this is a misuse we have the super
isis supporters who use this against
people who actually follow the sunnah
yeah these guys
you know where the strangers etc to get
mufti men
knitting and put it down as anyone that
anyone that doesn't say that's feminine
oh you or or anyone that calls you
extreme yeah
that all of a sudden you become this um
you know this this person who
is on the huck but they're not because
of that this is a misuse of hadith we
can't
apply this hadith somewhere and you
can't get this hadith and be like okay
this applies to this person or that
person that's wrong
pissed off man i'm working every day
almost
putting talking about muslim alphabet
society
pushing them to become leaders again
their wives are complaining they're not
mad enough
okay let me say okay women is this sexy
for you is this
attractive to you that some men is gonna
need some
orange thread today i have
eight sessions i'm i can you know mostly
marriage issues
and i can guarantee you that at least
out of those eight five will be related
to intimacy
and the women are saying my husband
doesn't
have the libido the strength why because
he's knitting man
okay here this is not only i would say
back biting but it's
you're literally insulting his integrity
you're literally insulted in terroristic
i'm not seeing you doing it on purpose
here but your frustration has made you
say something while
i genuinely believe i don't know you
brother while i you might be someone a
person i don't know you yeah
genuinely this is this is this is very
very crossing lines
did you question in a man's integrity
and you are basically saying in a
nutshell
that imagine i'm doing knitting and then
you say the statement you're basically
telling me that i can't satisfy my wife
because my wife will be complaining
saying look he's too busy knitting and
he's like a wimp
he can't even sexually uh please me this
is what you're trying to insinuate okay
i'm not seeing you intentionally doing
it but that is very very
hurtful and while it's something that
you should ask for forgiveness of the
purpose of person
because what you're seeing there it's so
disturbing yeah
and let me tell you something we heard
this i speak to him he has a marriage
counsel yeah
i speak to him most men are not pleasing
their wives
sexually you know why because they're
too busy watching pornography they are
too busy not lowering their gaze and
looking at other girls
that's why they can't even get excuse me
if there's kids watching this please
don't watch now yeah okay there are men
who can't even get an
erection you know why because they're
too busy
getting turned on by watching
pornography where it's fake
everything is fake they're getting this
most very attractive woman with
bodies implants god knows whatever that
looks like the perfect woman
special effects coloring you name it and
they're giving you a fake reality of
what intimacy is
and when this guy sees his wife well of
course he's not going to get an erection
so for us to get and make it seem as if
people who are knitting or maybe etc and
this is the reason no
that's not the issue and you know what
we've got a bit of a cure for this yeah
okay
okay so guys my sponsor one of my
sponsors nature's blind okay
this is called shilajit or whatever it's
called yeah
as far as i know yeah brothers if you've
got some sexual issues going on et
cetera wherever it may be
you need that extra boost turbo yeah
whatever it may be there's no shiny
religion when it comes to intimacy
check this out because i heard it's a
matching yeah as you can see guys i
haven't
opened it yet um yeah
i don't need it but yeah he's being
taught by chefs to knit and to be a baby
as opposed to real men
so of course you're gonna have low
libido of course you're not gonna be
able to please your wife oh brother ken
you're talking with yeah because that's
what the issues are man
again this is wrong yeah now there are
some studies i'll speak to my major
there are studies that show that when a
one
when a man did this study where they got
a teacher female teacher and a boxer and
they got them to change roles
yeah and the boxer became a teacher or
something along those lines and the
woman got into a bit of a boxing etc
it did show that her estrogen levels um
did drop and no the demand uh estrogen
testosterone levels dropped and the
woman's testosterone
levels uh testosterone levels got high
so it i do agree that the actions that
you do if you're acting like moving like
a woman it's going to affect that
however to blame knitting or stuff like
this
and make it seem as if that makes you
some kind of you know like a
wimp a feminine woman that's not
right and it is wrong and it's
questioning a man's intention
and it's actually insulting him now this
is the last point all right man
so yeah okay go ahead man that's your
solution
millions of likes oh [ __ ] it's so cute
woohoo millions go ahead
but that's not what we care man okay so
this is very interesting yeah to accuse
somebody that they're doing something
because of life etc
this is wrong this is someone's
intention you cannot question someone's
intention and say
oh you're doing this for likes this is
haram how are you going to question
someone's intentions
how do you know he's doing it for likes
and how do you know so brothers and
sisters please let's not go down this
route
i understand the brother's frustration
i'm with him i'm 100 with him but to
apply this on a specific individual and
make
take it all out on him it's a volume it
is absolutely from
um and to make it seem as if you know
he's doing it for likes and you're
saying oh i don't care i mean i don't
care about the opposite person that's
not true
that's not true we don't know that yeah
we do not know that you know just
because somebody doesn't have
mass amounts of followers et cetera
doesn't mean they're not doing it for
they're doing it for other than the sake
of allah or they're doing it for the
sake of allah it doesn't mean that
inshallah
prophet says that's it i don't want to
say anything anymore i hope i didn't
hurt this brother i genuinely gave my
feedback
um and yeah that's it from sisters you
know i've showed you guys like i said
before
i know mufti meng and believe me these
brothers if they knew mufti meg and they
knew some stuff
yeah but trust me they'll say this man
is a real man yeah
so inshallah miller bless you guys till
next time if you enjoyed this video
share with your friends and family
until next time i don't think i've
missed anything out goodbye